el secretario de estado mike pompeo dijo
que el régimen ilegítimo de maduro en
venezuela montó una farsa electoral que
pretende hacer pasar por elecciones
legislativas en el comunicado con pero
dice que condena esta parodia que no
cumplió con los más mínimos estándares
de credibilidad además agrega que casi
60 países y organizaciones de todo el
mundo incluidos eeuu la unión europea de
la organización de estados américanos el
grupo de lima y el grupo de contacto
internacional rechazan este simulacro
electoral
washington ya había afirmado que seguirá
reconociendo a juan guaidó como
presidente interino y elliot abrams
enviado especial para ese país resaltó
que además se vendrán sanciones para los
responsables del fraude electoral por su
parte yo bailé en presidente electo
también se ha manifestado en el pasado
diciendo que es hora de pasar la página
del régimen de nicolás maduro